especially when you're watching the game  because you know that magnus very well  are you reading into his body language  are you feeling the nerves uh as a  family  do you all discuss the moves  or do you try to kind of forget that  it's your son up there on the stage  you can't really forget that but  i've concluded that like  my wife she doesn't follow the games  very closely which is she gets too  nervous basically yeah well i like to  follow the games so i have this choice  should i follow the games and be nervous  or should i try to  avoid thinking too much about it but  kind of miss the excitement and i always  go for the excitement so  i seek that combination of  excitement and  pressure nerves  whatever and  the balance has been quite good so far  although  it's probably getting worse with every  match  and